pirates ödp free voters
animal protection party
volt one of these parties
have you probably wanted to vote before or
the biggest problem is fear for many
to give away your own voice
according to the motto they do not come in anyway
this is not only undemocratic
but shirt also the development of new
innovative parties
so conclusion
with this volt calls for the federal party conference
last week enough
we build the
through the introduction of the so-called substitute vote
so if for example volt is my heart party
then I tick volt
and write a2 in the box of the party
who is second to me
volt will not then manage the five percent hurdle
the voice automatically passes to my second wish
so is not given away
so you can in the small party without fear
and vote without abolishing the five percent hurdle
the five percent hurdle should be abolished
and what about the introduction of the replacement voice
your first time
write me in the comments